the Joe Rogan experience and so the
concept is terraforming right that is
that's not gonna happen I think even
Elon would tell you that's not gonna
happen in his lifetime that's something
that like generations from now we could
think about it's that's that's hard so
there's some sort of domed civilization
like what yeah okay yeah live and some
kind of pressurized compartment some
kind of pressurized habitat so it'd be
kind of like science fiction like what
you see in science fiction things for
ships land on planets and people live
inside the ships and you can't go
outside unless you wear a suit less wear
a suit yeah Wow
but hopefully there'll be plenty of
plenty room inside if once this thing
grows to be really big we also have to
make sure it's really really well
protected from radiation because even
once you're on Mars you have to worry
about those GC ARS and yeah yeah didn't
he have an idea to like nuke the caps
yeah like nuke the solar polar caps and
yeah you know it's not like anybody's
really sitting around drawing up plans
for that that was kind of like like if
we had to do it how could we do it
that's one thing you know that came off
the top of his head but what was that
was to raise the temperature or change
the atmosphere or that's there like melt
the captain and eject a lot of gas into
the atmosphere and beef up the Martian
atmosphere what a weird roll the dice
that would be I don't think we're gonna
be trying that ain't then what is the
concept like in terms of terraforming
what kind of window of time would it
take to turn that into a livable
environment that you're starting to
really extrapolate it out pretty far and
I'd be pretty hard for me to give you so
there's like giant leaps of technology
that have to take place that's that's a
big one but it's as a proof of concept
it's it's sort of I mean there is a
theory right the young can alter the
atmosphere and I mean Mars has got
enough gravity that if you could put
enough gas into the atmosphere it would
stick around mmm kind of like you know
it's it's got it's possible you're not
gonna get to one atmosphere pressure
like 14.7 PSI like we enjoy here but
might be enough
now and their their gravity is what
percentage of Earth's it's about third
third mile so you you would definitely
experience a lot of the same issues that
you have if you go to the Space Station
so if you wanted to go from Mars back to
Earth it would definitely be some sort
of an adjustment period yeah you know
the really interesting thing is like we
know we have a lot of data we know what
happens at in zero-g because we have a
lot of us have been up to the space
station and Skylab and mirror and all
that and we have tons of data at 1g
because all of us every day live in 1g
we don't really have any data in between
mmm so the question is is a half a G
half as good or maybe it's like 80% is
good right and and and so is it linear
or is it nonlinear we don't know mm-hmm
and that's why if we send people and we
live on the moon or we go to Mars and we
live on Mars and we have data a kind of
moon it's about 1/6 of the Earth's
gravity
so we'll get points in between and then
we can figure out if this thing is
there's a lot of stuff that happens to
you that may be completely solved but
even just a smallest amount of G hmm but
we don't know well that's interesting
right we don't know yeah because zero
G's an issue we don't know how much of
an issue
1/3 G is yeah now what about food like
what are they gonna do with food on Mars
are they gonna have to fly all the
ingredients out everything out would you
start talking about missions that are
that long carrying all your food with
you bringing it all becomes mass
prohibitive you know you just gotta take
so much and that just means you need
that that much bigger of a rocket and
it's just after a while it gets you know
to the point where it doesn't work
what's all the food for the rest of your
life essentially yeah so we're probably
if we're talking about like living for a
long time on Mars or even deep space
missions we gotta grow food so probably
plants hydroponically like the Matt
Damon movie yeah yeah
how realistic was that you know that
movie is really pretty good good movie
yeah there was a I met the author the
guy that wrote Andy weir
I wrote the book and I told them that I
really didn't like his book yeah he's
like why was it because like there's not
really enough dynamic pressure in a
Martian windstorm to knock the antenna
off the roof like now it's fine with
that
it was because we don't have enough
redundancy in the comm system and that's
not really realistic I'm like that no
because well why didn't you like it I'm
like well listen I have a long day of
work at SpaceX I come home I open up the
book before I go to bed and I'm reading
this like okay I got 62 Souls and I got
to cover 3000 kilometers and I've got 52
moles of nitrogen the hydroxide blah
blah blah and I'm like it's like I'm
still at work like I wanted some
escapism I want to like go home already
have romance now or something well
that's not his fault though
no well so you just busted his pollen
busting his balls yeah that's it's
interesting though that he got it close
yeah yeah he did a great job that's all
true I mean for something does he have a
background in that yeah I think he does
uh I hear something okay that makes more
sense yeah yeah but what that movie was
terrifying the idea that you can get
stuck up yeah the only part of the movie
which I don't think was in the book that
was not realistic at all was when he
cuts his glove and does the Iron Man
Thing oh he's like flying back to the
spaceship you can't really control it
that you spin out of control it's yes
you'd also need a big hole to really get
enough propulsion and then your suit
would deflate I mean it's just that's
just not gonna work
[Applause]